think I think indeed we need we need to
keep we keep witness me we need to keep
the support of these issues because as a
sham said what we have is a regime that
actually wants to rewrite history and
the honest truth honest truth was really
left of Libya are those of us who are
outside inside Libyans have impact being
reprogrammed totally broke and they
depend on us for their history they
depend on us for the language and so
it's very important that we and isn't
it's incumbent upon us what outside to
actually write live in history and
remind them of what they were remind him
of what they are and that it should
never accept this type of behavior or
any yet at any guns so I'm really happy
to see that taking place right now sir
what does reason why you guys are
suffering my apologies to you but I have
a soft spot belinea lived there for four
years when i was a kid i love the
honesty of the reasons which i suspect
is no longer the case because the regime
has such corrupting influence
says
but your point about
revising history reminds me were very
funny thing
back and easily they think of something
that
if all the Egyptian
hudye that happen
we had movie
30 or 40 is back before that
would carry the pictures of in Peru in
the background so they issued
instructions to block out
this way to blindly and instead of just
passing by allah ne noticing
it was entertaining everybody this is
king farouk yeah there is
revisionist history
my question to all of you got to answer
the only thing I find common
I take your point in the combos terrible
help of other places
find common errors other than Aaron is
Islam did you think
issue a shin of a Christian from the
all the way to be alone
no I mean I think also the truth the
truth is the truth is many of those
regimes find Islam okay hey direct
opposition to what they do here Gaddafi
the first thing he did was actually to
fight the Islamists he eliminated all
vestiges of his chemists within Libya at
school because he sees them as Michelle
we mean it's not for him is what
conforms his own view of the world
that's what Islam is to him so the first
thing he says well we will no longer
accept the traditional dates of Islam
what is the calendar handle itself he
changed Islamic calendar he says well
Muhammad was wrong but he said didn't
say wouldn't all our had no one to all
our hat so he wants to change the Quran
as well too so for him the ego is so
huge that he sees himself not only as a
prophet he seizes up more than that so
in the mock tolerate Richard I 10 won't
even bring Jesus right no don't bring us
down this fat ok they don't you see if I
may say I think the question of Islam
and is this
cheeky one and I think we should be the
actual I think the current crisis and
the frustration that you know permits
the airport children blind us to see a
lot of context it's easy to see in this
time of crisis a quick answer for things
and I i try to dust the learn that
lesson i learned from the colonial
period is not to quickly find a quick
answer for it sometimes that might be
satisfactory give you a quick answer but
also the problem would persist i think
what we when it comes to islam you know
um i think this is this is really a
common religion in general and islam
specifically is the fabric that permits
social and moral life in the region but
Islam also being appropriated by the
state's Islam also of all varieties
being nationalized by new groups that
emerged in the last 30 or 40 years so
the idea to talk about Islam as
sometimes we talk about it in the United
States is really troubling to me because
there is a search for a quick answer and
the quick answer is easy to find but
it's not going to resolve challenges
that are social and contemporary with
that of Islamic movements challenging
their states or states appropriating and
using Islam for in its own ends and the
this is a really an area where i find a
big flaw and the literature on Islam
because everybody talks about Islam you
know people who think that they were
born Muslim they can talk about Islam
will have read ten books or twenty books
they can write about Islam so it become
really the original sin that everybody
wants to find and that's I think that's
that's I find it could be a block to
understand the larger issues behind the
people's believe in their faith and
their
mortgage separation
the use of me jeans
I'm sure it may be like
well the case people
I meant if you took religion out of the
equation
correct me up
oh yeah there's lamas wendy is that the
messenger said the more democratic
opposition is always very easy to remove
but because it's very apparent that it
is open okay so what you would do you
find you find that opposition that is
not open unfortunately in this case
these llamas tend to be the their
clothes the clothes opposition but even
there gaddafi uses them to actually
silence all other movements and he has
done it Nathan besides the other factor
which is really very important that
libya's Islam is a very benign form has
always been so it really is not I mean
to think to compare the bit aside the
Arabia or Iran is little sensor help you
can't even get them to Egypt Egypt is
not a Muslim that says that even Libya
Libya system is very benign it's very
it's very instinctive in a sense there's
a mixture of of of Islam and traditions
and some food isn't some you know it's
by the nature of the beers are like that
and so I don't it plays your pond roll
not say you know islam is very is very
important in libyan life but not in the
sense that that is hegemonic in
determining the system it's not it
serves the censorship for individuals
it's very powerful censorship but what
is right and what is wrong and the
regime uses that very cleverly and very
very smartly ok to actually to maintain
the edge and what they want to do do you
have a question yes actually I think we
can um you know pull out a few common
themes from all of our panelists and
we've talked about brutality we've
talked about oppression I mean it was
during it was present during the period
of colonization and these constant these
constant shocks did they keep continuing
so I wonder if anyone would like to
comment on this this issue of continuity
and this constant state of exception
sure so that's a very very smart
question very very smart question like
so yeah so I won't answer it but I will
say this though I will say that the view
that what Monroe said earlier the view
that intellectual capital and any agency
for progress and change in Libya is if
and should plan to do correctly then
it's sort of held by Libyans abroad and
that the libyans there are basically
exhausted and bankrupt intellectually I
resist that because I think certainly
Libya has lost a lot of a lot of its its
its people to exile but I remain an
optimist you know there are so many
sizes and think about dictatorship is
that it's it's got all the all the
agencies for self-destruction er are
implanted in it you know the KT ships by
a large don't last as as long as
democracies to and so I think it's just
it that is one once one reason why
optimistic but the other reason why I'm
optimistic is that I can see all these
young writers in Libya publishing to you
know writing and journals blogging which
has become a phenomenon yes the writing
isn't you know great but there's a real
hunger for for expression for recording
life there's you know this dignity to be
had in stating the present in language
and that sort of you know all those
reasons give me give me optimism Libya
is yes way behind and it's a tragic
state of affairs but there's still that
thing that can never be destroyed by any
dictator
film that is growing and is so that
those are those my my very weak reasons
for being an optimist so someone else
not to answer this question I think this
is a very very tough question a good one
there are certain facts that we need to
know about modern Libyan that when a
century which is I think for example up
until 1930s what we might call civil
society or society was has been always
stronger than the state Libya until
death in 20th century has been dominated
by rural forces not urban forces and I
think Libyans when they after they went
through the brutal colonization they
faced the 20th century with the federal
constitutional monarchy that was
modernizing but at the same time they
think the fact that the state the
central state has been recent Libyan
called a Libyan society and more than
Libyan culture that will be really a
cliche to say in my opinion has been
really reluctant in dealing with the
modern nation-state and that could be a
problem could be an interesting
challenge Italian corazon failed if we
compare it with the fact that the French
created an elite francophone elite um
you know um people in the other mugabe
states and also in egypt i would say
segment of the egyptian elite has been
also a socialized to look at europe in
that way but in some sense Libyan
society has not really and that problem
is acute now after 69 is um to accept
the nation-state and to continue the
building and the modernizing process
that started after 1951 and what kind of
state is going to be erected there
or arm to build an indigenous
institutions and mix it with modern
institutions so in that sense I think
modern Libya despite the tragedies to me
is a very interesting society because
when the society has been strong in up
until 1930s and from 1951 until nineteen
sixty-nine it managed to create
something really that a weaker state
actually might be a positive thing
that's maybe one of the listening
learned now that society uncrushed
nationalized and we need to UM
consequences that unintended now the the
lessons of the last 40 50 years is
something very different is Lisa wrote
about the disruption about institution
between 19th century and 20th century
network and disruption or the
discontinuity is really has been a heavy
harvard's for Libyan people because
every time there is a change there will
be eradication of the dealer
institutions the Italian destroyed that
the Ottoman institution the solution
institutions and then after nineteen
sixty-nine the destruction of the Union
institutions and I think in the sense
that added to the crisis that that's
there well but i'm i'm up to a pessimist
here because history give you lessons to
go backward and some time is listen to
go forward and there have been
experience even when it's really cute i
think in those indigenous institution
and the tenacious ability to libyan to
be healthily are suspicious of the
central government might be revived next
time that's not going to be easy because
that's going to take a lot of work
before you kind of revive these
traditions that existed before in other
words i see a lot of complexity a lot of
potentials but it's not an easy quick
answer no I was
I was once a participant to some Island
out in us in Washington DC some think
tank and somebody asked me something
about possibility of about cool guys get
there him a popular uprising and I said
well might be look at what's happening
in Serbian I need man said well are you
comparing reviews to the Serbs smes he
says well you can't and I took offense
at it but the thing back is right i mean
what society has been going through 40
years and nothing has changed it the
bigger problem here and I think I
thought he touched up on that is that
civil society was never given time to
develop mean you know you know I make it
and you can see it very clearly the type
the type of colonialism the British when
they occupy the society whether it's
India Nigeria also done you know the
dealt with those societies through
institutions and so even if you have a
problem in Nigeria but something they
have a part in that they have some sort
of institutional framework which they
can revert to they can go back to same
thing with India India that we do tend
to forget that India is the largest
democracy in the world partly thanks to
the British public thanks submission of
doing that for establishing institutions
the British never interred in tomorrow
door or in involve themselves in other
societies the occupied per se they dealt
through institutions the French on the
other hand you know didn't really care
as long as you ate french spoke French
dead French they would go they would go
to a society pick up a small tribe
Christianize it and put it in power and
this francophone a couple girls like
that but there is Chad what is share
whatever it is there's a problem the
Spaniards basically give you a choice
either becomes Spanish or die and we're
over here yeah
Italians did not even give the limping
as that choice and that thing what you
saw up there was very clear they
ultimately mean we talked we talked
about the decimation of the population
yes the Italians were intent upon
decimating Libyan publishing the world
was superfluous Libya was the foreshore
anyway the institution that created was
not for the benefit of Libyans was
whenever the battalion's and hence we
never really saw the development of
civil society in Libya the few years we
saw that from 1951 1 169 we saw the
emergence of that we saw literary clubs
we saw the formation of a particular
parties we saw a variety of institutions
that that never had before when so
unions coming up we saw the beginning of
civil society but it was aborted aborted
okay fine abort it but put something
else instead so you find a huge vacuum
there has been going on for the last 40
years and not not being filled you talk
about change he decided last week that
he wants to change the currency again so
now the Libyan currency is twice now the
third time this year but anyone who has
money they earn money now is useless
unless they bring it and put it in the
background is this constant shifting
this constant inability to develop the
civil society because ultimately only
civil society and in fact hold the
government accountable do you Franz
today you have demonstrations by few
notice you find the farmers you find all
kinds of groups to the Cyclops's no we
don't want that Libya society those
groups never evolve never developed this
is a conscious policy and therefore this
is why I'm not optimistic
I'm not optimistic but I've seen it
another 14 years mix it I'm what I worry
I worry i worry about next generation of
libyans you have taken too long I'm
sorry I Bahamut didn't send to do that
um let me just point out of course the
Italians were in control such as it was
of Libya for 30 years in Gaddafi's been
in control of Libya for four years
that's just and I think I also want to
sort of open another issue that i will
leave it to you to follow up on if you
are interested his sham talked a little
bit about the edible issues in Libya of
course we have at least one and perhaps
two or three sons of Gaddafi who are
considered plausible successors to him
and I think one of the interesting
things we might be wanting to talk about
a little bit as the prospect for any of
those and the issue that that raises
about continuity and change because of
course I feel alone for example says
that he thinks that there should be a
constitution in Libya and he is very
much associated with a
institution-building kind of project in
Libya and yet of course represents some
of the uninstallation and so that
tension is very much your question it
seems to me is very much related to that
what constitutes continuity and what
constitutes change in a circumstance
where what has been continuous has been
changed if I may add to that I would
just say that several months ago there
was probably in an article in the
newspapers where it was discussed that
CEFs youth councils would replace the
Revolutionary Committees not sure any of
you came across that but I thought I
might interject that
Neil y sub 1 i'm a practical question on
that level you said to know that had 40
years of men linked malignancy and mark
they stood by idiosyncrasy in the only
things don't change that is is actually
stepping animal you know what you
thought in step down as we stepped in
the degrade so is there any side of that
and then what happens next to the
children compete and you know safe
stains are all well and good but you
know we've seen the same process in
Syria and Jordan disarming the saga
where the smart come into talking sir
Moxie but it requires taking bart with
your father's built-ins to do that I
mean I don't have I mean just get with
the baby I'm beg for this one second
let's look it is a little bit more on
the past I had not I mean my in my life
I have not seen any Arab leader I've
seen only two Arab leaders resign good
evening okay the rest were carried out
can I got back with a Lorraine right
right okay one was some Sudan and the
other moves Algeria okay
the people own awesome Wow oh yeah fine
okay no sorry two hours okay it's about
dogs so what about okay I Shadley misty
yeah no that doesn't count so let them
go get that one there it was hey my book
yep lemon is different no let me there's
no state there's elections but I'm
saying yes it is it is a dilemma it's a
busy I mean the water the world today
them so much is going on the hostile
world perhaps the most stable part of
the woods the Middle East I've ever seen
more stability than you see the Middle
East no one else so the question right
whose ticket after yes cadet he has
children now do they redo serve to be
perhaps yes but the system will be
tailored very much like Syria I mean
really it's against fact I didn't study
into the personality of leadership with
Libyan here's a man who had a coup
against what he perceived to be as
backwardness in the form of monarchies
he went lots of Libya's money and effort
and lives were spent in fighting whether
it's the Morocco fighting Jordan or
fighting whatever it is okay they wanted
neither East no West as far as monitors
were concerned and yet what does he end
up being in other wants to make himself
a king I'm on the irony in all of this
that not only does he do what comfort
what contradicts what he has always been
saying but he finds justification to do
the contradiction is he going to leave
one of his children's in power yes which
are the children will be the power I
think my person thing I think be safe
but he understands something which which
is another element which has not been
talked about the billions of dollars
that he had at his disposal what do the
others want the question there is no
there is no accountability in Libya when
when when his second son third son from
second song to the second wife said
decided he wants to sign a 25 billion
dollar deal with an Emirati company to
build the chalets and no somewhere in
west of Tripoli okay did he ask anyone
was there a parliament would anyone said
yes you can do that I mean all of this
is show what you see what you see what
you see in the formal institutions that
he has so the show they have no power
safe and huge what you think that
there's a person who has studied as
lived in Europe who are certain the
London School of Economics who
understands what the model has lived the
force of democracy he understand what
possibly means and yet does he want to
do he pays a tip service in the final
analysis relaxed with his father has
that and he will continue what his
father's do it will not change I
actually if I may want to complicate
that a little bit um because I think
there is an interesting dilemma
confronting someone in safes position
because he's in his position because of
course he is the leaders son but he is
also one of the few people his age who
is in fact fluid in English is educated
in Europe know something about the way
the rest of the world works this was a
country under deep deep sanction we
didn't talk about that we talked about
the Italians we talked about the
revolution but we didn't talk about the
effect of the sanctions and the
sanctions were very corrosive so it's
partly the revolution and it's partly
the sanctions but the fact that Libya
went under sanction and on the eve of
one of the great technological
revolutions of human history at a time
so that
you know from the time I got email to
the time i got my smartphone they
basically weren't there there were no
credit cards there was no nothing so
that generation of libyans has been
playing catch-up now quickly and you
know all that sort of stuff but it does
mean that safe has had a window under
the world that is quite unusual for a
Libyan for that generation of Libyans so
it means that he he has an opportunity
because of the fortune that he had in
being not only his father son but taken
under the wing of people who would take
him to Vienna and have him go to
business school and then help him get
into lse and oh you know the life that
he led so that now he's you know a
student of David held and you know so he
so it is it's an interesting challenge
for him he understands the the position
he plays in the country that the fortune
he has had if you will he does know what
institutions are he does know there
isn't a single institution in Libya and
it there is this interesting moment
where a figure like that and it is true
that there isn't none of the that this
generation of people who have succeeded
their father has done anything
particularly remarkable in that but
everybody the optimists the genuine you
know sort of completely Pollyanna
optimists look at King Juan Carlos how
do you get from fascism in Spain from
Franco to democracy you have a pivotal
figure who comes up as the picked air of
Franco Franco picked that man and said
he's going to succeed me he's the one
who's going to continue fascism and as
soon as Franco is dead in as soon as
want Carlos was king he said no this is
a democracy this is stupid so the
question of what made spain spain and
made serious Syria so that somebody with
things you know cosmopolitan educated
England so forth and so on Bashar Assad
ends up being captured by his father's
system and King Juan Carlos didn't
disappoint well it's my super civil
society I think I know it is spain had
an industrial base is a civil society
soaked with its own that made it much
more plausible depressed lately
absolutely and also i think it was I
think a lot of what happened in Spain
happened because it is in a continent
that wouldn't have tolerated the
european ladies paid through the nose
for that democracy yeah shut up a loose
rein on his fame but chilly too I mean
come come back Chile under Pinochet what
the fascist dictatorship but what made
the change but what about what would end
this chili is ruined now we have a
democracy in Chile I think also means
something else to say about people like
safe or taken taking them at face value
what they say looking at their
experience and what they were exposed to
it or not I think one gets the sense
that a lot of people who want to make
things different in Libya and who are in
some way implicated or involved with the
regime are also tired and frustrated by
the idiosyncrasy and the absurdity of of
the dictatorship I'll give you an
example what is the number one demand
the number one Libyan demand from the
British government it is it is it you
know international respects ability
through doing these projects or all the
obvious things is completely
counterintuitive the number one demand
that the Libyan government has asked the
British government for is Qaddafi
dressed up to the nines
his military uniform and the golden
wagon going up her mouth to visit the
Queen SK this cuz articulate to kind of
depth of absurdity and also gotta just
daily life of a Libyan bureaucrat is not
actually very attractive they might have
you know they might they might have the
advantages of you know being able to
send their kids abroad and they might
have the advantages of luxury and money
and security things like that but I
don't have the impression that they are
happy or that they are content with the
situation and this kind of these two
extremes where the decision becomes more
and more more idiosyncratic and absurd
and the people supporting it become
happy and more and more more access to
the world and sending the kids abroad
and I think eventually there'll be a
critical point where one hopes that you
know these forces of change would would
be allowed a chance and it might not
work but I think it I think also
something else to say about the examples
given Syria and Morocco and so on I'm
not as negative about them as I think my
fellow panelists are it's obviously not
an ideal state of affairs that you know
one dictator is replaced by a lot of
dictators happens to be a son because it
gives us serve a sense of infinity like
this could go on forever but there are
some serious changes that have happened
particularly in Morocco I think that I
think should be the envy of a lot of
Arabic countries you know the fact that
it still remains prisoners political
prisoners in mark of course I know that
but no other Arabic country close
political prisons in such a public way
following the truth and reconciliation
ain't no it's highly imperfect but they
try to do it and they went some way into
doing it they have school trips for
children to HUD remote and such you know
hideous places you know
and so you know it's not ideal but I
think looking you know the long view and
it's very difficult to imagine Morocco
going back to what it was and I think in
another hundred years now and of course
we want an immediate kind of you know
sunshine but it's not gonna happen I
think things gonna be a long long
process so having somebody like safe
replace Qaddafi will be you'll break
many people's hearts but including mine
but i think it is moving in it given the
options that we have it's moving in the
right direction it was obviously the
other silent option is a military
general who's plotting away in the dark
and throws everything over and we have
another you know military dictatorship
with I actually I'm gonna put my three
cents in here first of all I think set
safes problem because he is his father's
son in some respects is that it's not
clear whether his enthusiasm for reform
and for constitutionalism and so forth
and so on is another idiosyncratic folly
or legit and that's just a very hard
position to be in I mean boom it's so
that's one thing the other thing is I
actually think the alternative is not a
boom etienne not a military dictator but
but uh coming apart at the seams I
actually think that that Libya does does
run the risk of basically a low-level
Civil War yeah yeah not so that's that's
another season to say you know what
keeping the thing together might be
better than not and I think that's the
and I totally agree with you I think
Libya today is infuse that ultimately
Gaddafi course you'll have a civil
all the civil war that will see how for
the publishing murdered that that is I
had no doubt about that yeah right can I
say a quick comment here I think the
difficulty of the few posts are Gaddafi
Libya has to do with the fact the system
even though as part of the RF system in
many ways then it would be really
important to keep that in mind is that
there is no clear vision or
constitutional or political process that
you know um indicate what's going to
happen after the leader dies or whatever
happens to him and also the system has
been for the last 20 years or 30 years
or so and I am glad that Lisa brought
the question in the sanctions because
has renders impact in many ways for
informal institutions has become really
the way and um this is I mean in Syria
you have a political party whatever that
that nature you have a bureaucracy in
Morocco you have a monarchy and I think
those institutions have a mechanism to
resolve some of these issues of
succession and Libya is going to be
complicated because so far even after
Gadhafi Colonel Gaddafi's statement and
he's tried to appoint his son saif
al-islam as a monastic amnesia and get a
Sharpie or yeah coordinator for the you
know she committed not revolutionary not
the people feel these committees yes
yeah so um that kind of fizzled a little
bit and and and that's the definition of
the difficulties but I would like to be
at you know stare or attention a little
bit different I think um I think a
question of leadership is huge and one
source is has every right to highlight
that um
I think what we some time is overlooked
is the change it within Libyan society
for example there is a genome-wide
movement among intellectuals academics
you know human rights organizations now
you know I'm pushing for reform from
within and we often we don't hear about
them because they don't have access to
arabic I know some of them I
participated in some of these
conferences recently and they really are
people who are lobbying and they're
confronting other groups like the
Revolutionary Committees and other
groups and I i would say that safe is
probably you know we write to look at
him within the larger picture of the
leadership in the top but there is also
a segment of Libyan society that is
pushing for change and they sometimes
being suppressed some time is there you
know I'll kind of silence they have this
newspaper they have this journal and
they come on and can I say also one of
the most overlooked things is the
thriving Libyan literature the short
story writers the poet's the women of
writing that's in Arabic and I think
what what all they tell us is not a
romantic idea but that there is now
society generating its own voices yes
it's sometimes quite sometimes you
cannot really be daring but these are
force are really trying to advocate a
fight corruption I try to advocate the
idea of rule of law trying to push for
freedom of press for example that's a
big fight now in Libya that newspapers
journals are pushing for
right to allow groups to be represented
and have their own voices the fight over
for example the lawyers guild or the
Writers Union that's incredible fight
the fight over the presidency of
Benghazi University which I know there
are old and people are blogging and
trying to express themselves I'm not
talking about the Exile that's a
different story I think within Libyan
society there are a lot of groups that
in so many ways trying to confront the
harvest the to the book tries but
nothing nothing concrete is you see that
because the regime does not allow these
groups to actually possible to be active
the company will discover emerges they
cut it off what newspaper do you see set
up by anything beside the regime we are
they are they are for example oh yeah
and arena began to have quietly suppress
some opinions for example their ex viras
apology which most of its right away
from media publishing cairo but i think
it's incredible it's published in cairo
publish you in my mother but distributed
in libya and I'm just understand very
much like like like these Islamic
Islamic countries when they learn a
whole conference you don't hold in
stomach on the old in Cyprus I know what
is no one saw but what I think I think
it's understand we have to look at those
voices and context they might not be as
able to express themselves but there is
now a general wine fight about for
example the civil society the the
Revolutionary Committee say there is no
such thing this is a Western invention
and other groups are replying to them
they say no there is a civil society
we're going to fight for it and and I
think these these are not just chaotic
or marginal debates these are I think
important fights maybe small ones as I
mean there's an American social
scientist whom I admire very much has a
book called hidden transcript he talks
about the public transcript and the
hidden transcript for the dominated
people I think you'll find a lot of
hidden transcript in Libya now and these
things might be really crucial may be
advocating as we were talking may be
supporting civil stand for
all kind of reasonable reasons or other
other other groups but we should we'll
make a mistake of law of overlooking
those groups that might not be visible
to us okay I mean very quickly uncle she
Lisa made a very good point and the good
point is that is that the economic
suicide from 70 8211 for yeah but in
that period of time the world has
changed dramatically we have we have the
iphone where I broke an iphone and then
we have so much that the country can't
afford to be to be to be working in eggs
can't can't do it and save the standards
of providing an alternative indeed his
following in the same same footsteps and
then when you talk about the Gaddafi
foundation it's an NGO what NGO but tell
me an NGO SS captioned by the government
in Libya new not actually jared in
Switzerland yeah yes sir
who
after questions what explains the
success of the food why was the glue so
16 and then what is what explains the
persistent
one of the causes of God why has been
redeemed successfully is it was the
social basis of the regime I thought
this was a small question that's a very
that's it the biggest question of all
let me say a few things about it and
I'll it my colleagues are commenting
this it's not true that 1969 was an
isolated cool it's not true the junior
officers who top of the the modernizing
institution monarch in Libya were very
popular at the beginning and that's the
danger of reading history in project in
history in the past now what happened
since you know the mid-seventies on
there were a lot of changes among the
the group that did you know the cool
weather usually whatever you want to
call it and then after that a new regime
began to rise and led to the things that
um you know monsoon wrote about and
others which led to other kind of
changes within the mid society and
politics I think now also it's very very
conducive to look at why some Libyan
youth were radicalized in the 1960s as
why Libyan some of Libya news began to
read the article I Sanaa 98 earlier
became nationalism our Muslim brothers
and also leftist affiliations and in the
1980s Islamic movements and other groups
who began to confront the state I think
only by looking at these really specific
context we can understand it and we
understand the rhetoric of nationalism I
happen to be argue it's a very
controversial argument earlier part of
the legitimacy of the officers was the
delayed their breasts nationalism
and and you know military bases and and
all of that that's up to a point then
after that became a new security
apparatus a new state a new leadership
that that became uncontrolled the state
and became a war against enemies either
you are with me or against me see the
zero-sum game yeah so love you I guess
yeah but I think your question is really
can do and I mean a very very insightful
in the sense we have to relook at the
contest and what period and what change
that would help us understand what goes
on and then in the 1970s and the 80s and
after the Lockerbie crisis can I just
say one or two things about this very
good question very large question first
of all keep in mind that at the time
when the when Gaddafi came to power
there were half a dozen coos in the
making some of which were supported by
the Egyptians and some of which were
supported by the Americans and so forth
these guys just got there first so it
wasn't as if that was a very stable
well-regarded regime under the monarchy
was obviously going to fall over and it
just was a question of who got there so
when we talk about institutions we
should not romanticize the monarchy
there were no institutions there either
so and this is part of the 20th century
they were in my view institutions in
1910 and that was about the last time
because the Italians did everything they
could to destroy the institutional
design and makeup of the country the
British and French did nothing to
rebuild it when they were the occupiers
during the war the monarchy was unable
to do that and the oil money swamped
whatever efforts they may have been able
to make and so this is the 20th century
we're finished now but that's part of
the problem and I so that's one point
about that the other thing is that I
think what's interesting is we have
several times all of us in different
ways said the fact that Gaddafi has been
in power for 40 years doesn't mean that
it's been 40 at same years there's been
different quite distinct
periods within that 40 years and it's
important to acknowledge in a sense that
one of the ways he stayed in power is to
do is to recognize that I mean he
himself was the engineer of some of
those changes so a regime that came in
in the 1970s very very opposed to
tribalism ends up in the 1990s
completely turning around on so it's a
very different regimes so in a sense it
is true that internationally it was a
pariah and now it's you know everybody's
welcomed it back into but domestically
there was that kind of change over the
course of time that was of you know in
fact we have to credit that regime for
having been as flexible and objective to
stay in power under those circumstances
the one other thing that I want to say
is if you want a really elegant examine
of how the radicalization of a regime
can kind of sneak up on you read this
read in the country of men you watch it
was sneaking up on people in the end of
the 1970s people who had been young
people particularly very excited about
this new young group of you know
nationalists and they'd overthrown this
embarrassing monarchy and now Libya was
something in the world and so forth and
so on it snuck up on everybody how
bizarre and off the rails this system
was getting and it's just it's entering
that period is particularly interesting
in my view for that if I may in 1978 I
was walking down in Benghazi and there
was a demonstration University
University students demonstrating the
streets and one of the kids looked at me
and I feel so Shane glad i didn't i
didn't join then does it mean sesame
join me tomorrow he'll come for you I
looked at him
it and sure enough two years later I was
walking down coming down from my home
and the traffic was pushed in one
direction and I had to follow that
direction it took me before a square but
I so let's saw two people being hung up
strung up and the first it came to my
mind was that kid was said to me join me
tomorrow here come for you you said yeah
can you say one thing to in response to
your question this year I think also you
know one of its the one of the reasons
for the team success it's actually it's
sort of it's genius actually I think it
lies at the heart of of its ability to
to change and to remain in power is that
it doesn't have a consistent political
ideology it's not on the left it's not
on the right sometimes it's on the left
sometimes sometimes but sometimes we
were told to to look towards kuba and
then Sunday were told to look towards
Abu Dhabi you know it's a very best made
very agile and inflicted on the Libyan
population a kind of in constant anxiety
because you don't nothing is permanent
everything's changing all the time um I
think another way particularly in those
early years in the 70s and also in the
80s the Qaddafi regime it was obvious
that they could have killed more people
than they killed but they taken a
decision I think to kill as few people
as possible but in the most dramatic way
as possible so in squares on television
and so on and that really did send the
shivers you know I mean you know
anecdotally I mean you know there are
many people I know in deep here who
um you know f I have one of my many
cousins lives he lives full time in
England and he is a he's a medical
doctor and as it happened at some point
we lived in the same place and I mean we
still lives in the same area we were
probably about the three minute walk
from one another and until this day I
can't get him to have a cup of tea with
me not because he disagrees with me but
because of just because he's scared is
frightened and a lot of Libyans are
continue to be to have this kind of
almost sort of most kind of instinctive
fear it's all irrational it's so absurd
actually that you should be scared of
you know but it's it's it's the regime
succeeded in doing this in a very
effective way in a very modern way by
using television
follow is it possible
regime success
is related to its control resources and
the fact that the way that if she makes
a living is very little to do with
actively exploiting the population just
yeah but I guess we forgot to say that
part yes but also all so it doesn't fall
under the influence of I mean libya's is
unique in this regard it doesn't need
handouts it doesn't fall under the
influence of its X colonial master but
also I think Gaddafi's success you know
in being internationally influential
comes from one of the reasons I think
that Libya in general was keen on this
sort of thing at that time it's kind of
dreams of grandeur in a small South
Mediterranean country with very few
people you know wants to be wants to
punch above its weight Qaddafi succeeded
in doing that by funding you know by
basically being a troublemaker for the
West for a long time that now he can
negotiate we can now he can have this
kind of you know stature with them and
leverage uses to you just one thing I
was just hoping if we could consider the
villa's relationship with other states
particularly the United States and
Europe I mean as Libya has gone through
its fluctuations so has its relationship
with the West if you would like to
comment on that right No ok I will then
know I the the interesting thing to me
about the ultimate negotiations to lift
the sanctions and so forth it's on was
the extent to which particularly the
United States was put into a position
where the they did drop the demand for
regime change which the sanctions were
designed to produce and the sanctions
were not so the American sanctions were
not supposed to be lifted until there
was a change in the regime and again I
think this is a the fact that the
jim has been able to negotiate through
all of this and stay in power is a
credit to its agility and you know kind
of political savvy and lack of Vidya
logical consistency but it's but it was
you know in the late Clinton period when
saiful Aslam convinced his father and
his father wouldn't listen to anybody
else that if he wanted to have any kind
of legacy he was going to have to
wriggle out of the sanction regime under
which the country was laboring at that
point and thanks largely to September
11th they were able to produce enough
interesting information and material for
the United straight in the United States
to accomplish that but it so in that
sense it it is really ultimately about
the stability of the regime and that so
the policy changes and it's and the
regime is the consistent thread all the
way through
security resources and its access to
resources
why has that not been the case for
example
and countless other air
lashing
Curtis Libya is an alternative to Libya
it will cost much more in terms of first
of all military offensive and America's
position in the world and so forth
doesn't need to ask the soon as long as
there are alternatives to what we have
today why not America is five percent of
our communities no more don't forget
that much of its orders are companies it
comes from not in a Mexico concern come
from Canada comes from the United States
as well an African comes from the Angola
okay that's what that's worth Nigeria
this this is where this all comes from
it's more trouble than it's worth but
again just to answer the question which
he asked that I think this is very
important I mean I'm a firm believer
that we still exists within the
westphalian state and the Westphalian
state is dominated by national interests
it's not in the interest of United
States to to to to actually engage in
these in these offensive they can get
what they can get Iraq has a mistake
rund I've done by it by my foolish
policymakers but I don't there's a way
to to cause this with Gaddafi why not
because ultimately what can get that we
do as long as isn't practiced terrorism
as long as put in a box why not he
actually I'm yes I know I know he he
also in that sense I mean get Fe part of
the post 9-11 policy shift was to
provide all this information event al
Qaeda was great yes it wasn't about the
invasion it was not about the invasion
of Iraq that's why I said it started
under Clinton the Libyans were knocking
on the American store under Clinton and
they didn't finish it Martin Indyk wrote
writes about this they didn't finish it
Bush came in condoleezza rice & Company
said we are not going to talk to those
Libyans and they cut it all off on the
morrow of sep tember 11th the libyan
said you know who had the first Interpol
warrant out for bin Laden it was us we
know who these people are and we can
give you everything and the CIA was
meeting with them within 48 hours and
they told
what they knew and that was it it wasn't
about Iraq and then they had to
manufacture a whole set of you know what
are you going to do about the weapons of
mass destruction and so forth and so on
it wasn't about Iraq it was about the
Libyans needing to get the kind of
support the Algerians God against their
Islamic from the rest of the world and
it was about the Americans not knowing
anything about who these people were so
it's even funny because it there was a
remark that Gaddafi made during that
period saying you know what most of the
terrorists are in Europe and everybody
laughed and laughed you know what is he
talking about well in fact where were
most of the terrorists I mean it's
really interesting that whole period you
actually it's worth looking at closely
it wasn't about Iraq at all it was about
domestic Libyan politics and their need
to get out from under the sanctions in
order to get regional and international
support for their own trying to get rid
of their Islamist opposition which they
knew were all remember when we used to
talk about the Arab Afghans all the
people from the Arab world that taught
that that fought in Afghanistan well
they they were all over North Africa
they were in Algeria but the Algerians
had support from the United States
support from the French so forth and so
on during their war in the 1990s the
Libyans had the same problem mostly in
Seneca and they didn't have any
international support at all and they
realized that they were going to be just
sucked into this forever if they
couldn't get out that was the background
to the decision that they were going to
try and get out from under the sanctions
and it was scifil Islam who thought of
it of course they got out of it but but
they all agree but every I mean if you
look at the literature the Prime
Minister Shoukry Clennam cycle is slump
everybody said we just pay to get out of
this we don't think we did it but it
doesn't matter we paid billions to get
out of it but we had to but finally we
had an American administration that was
willing to let us pay the billions and
get out that's what they needed so they
got they got rid of what was claimed to
be a weapons of mass destruction program
they paid the money on Lockerbie they
all said where this is a dog and pony
they said we're being hypocritical it's
the only way we can get out and it
worked now did it leave a bad taste
about the you know fidelity to the rule
of law and so forth in the international
system well probably it still worked
this is me going what the system is over
exactly sir in the Marian unrest or even
the Civil War who would the players be
honest dual major regional issues
between private issues on there are
there for
within the military different factions
only the players yes saara naked to
potato mousse probably the zen will so
be was so be it outside player i think
very much so but it actually it would
indeed be between through betanians or
naked consolations think that they are
being abused by the regime I'm not
everybody is not mistaken Jamaica's more
than anything because everything so it's
a naked think they'd be abuse for two
reasons first of all they say the oil is
from Sarah nigga this is one because
what they say and the water is from
Seneca and both those commodities are
being pumped out of cyrenaica and yet
nothing is being done inside me just the
other factor to which is more important
that Gaddafi has in fact been very large
to masonic because so much of position
is coming i'm sorry nigga and don't
forget remember his but what that
daughter and he said it's quite right it
is a zero-sum game is on i if you not
with me you're against asaram a key has
been against the demonstrations have
been selected been against the attempted
attempted codes have been from Salonika
against and so and so it's been very
harsh and sarah niggas on 42 understand
we being adapted between triple taneous
anyone else
I think it's true yet and we have in the
eastern region as I mentioned a more
sense of of being really you know
neglected and an overlooked and
repressed but i think the concerns now
you know I'm cross other regions the
idea is now we are facing tremendous
social economic malaise subsidy
education health is an institution are
really in the worst situation and also
unemployment we're talking about three
in life issues that we are not talking
about just you know when we're going to
change their the system I don't think
that's really you know um I think people
are talking about daily are alive
activities and daily concerns and the
the fact that over a million people
Libyans go to Tunisia they sell their
jewelry and and and and they sell they
go in debt to just be treated there it
shows you the magnitude of the problems
that are round now I think as far as um
the possibilities that we keep coming to
it which is I think they're just of your
question here the answer has to be
qualified against certain forces there
is of course on the top the leaders
children there is um the security
apparatus there's also the old guard
there is also the regional and tribal
you know a fortune that also have been a
force as well and the army marginalized
but also the same you know it has some
some some saying in this I think anybody
who tell you that there will be a
concrete scenario they were pretty
misleading you there are all these
possibilities now and right now the
specter of civil word i think that's
removed from it but it depends what what
will be done in the coming years to
resolve these issues and saif al-islam
even though it might be not the really
the solution
he vents and echoes a lot of concerns
and the most Libyans are concerned about
so in a way is as far as saying that
really the things that people feel when
they say Libya is a failure we have no
our economy its total disaster our
experiment is over we need to have a
constitution we have a rule of law
freedom of the press freedom of assembly
we need to build the infrastructure
mostly bein say yes this is exactly how
we feel now how to make that transition
it's not an easy nut because of course
most people agree with that but also we
have to have to remember it's not this
good you know this is really the problem
we have a complex situation where groups
who are vested interest and they are
fighting to keep the status quo and
there are other groups who are fighting
are also how about that change so far
it's been peaceful which is I think
great for uh you know on the vast
majority of Libyans with that you know
I'm disintegrate into a violent one I
agree this is a possibility but so far
the specter of Somalia or certainly I
don't think it's there it would be
really misleading the situation if I may
I mean again I come back this issue why
I think that he's doing on Uncle anism
is important unfortunately rightly or
wrongly CERN akins have always seen
themselves did it is very very very much
like what what the Holocaust is for the
Jews because because Salonika has bore
the brunt of that they feel that
something must be made up that they were
responsible for continuing the
resistance they continued resistance in
1932 and and others did not know rightly
or wrongly this this is what the
perception is and I think this has
constantly been been a factor in the
they're thinking you're very right when
he says a million people from as she
gota to an easier sell the jewelry so
that can be treated the same thing
happens when you look at cyrenaica that
go to Jordan in fact in Jordan hospices
special hospitals to create new penis
and dip and people pay everything they
have because of the lack of medical
facilities within the country fingers a
wonderful figures I mean I really they
really are I look at bigger it will try
to book the CIA move back my little
figures but that the GNP GDP fourteen
thousand dollars per per capita GDP of
the 919 T 2 billion dollars but these
are figures that bear no resemblance to
the actual facts on the ground the
problem in Libya is that there is no
infrastructure that there are no
hospitals take care of people that
people don't have the funds to actually
pay to feel themselves the system is not
capable of hitting them it was capable
of taking care of them say that Islam
may talk as much as he wants but the
talking has to stop and the acting must
be shocked if he was suited to my suit
we could say about I'm sorry you're all
right do you have any no we have come to
the end of our session I have certainly
enjoyed myself I want to thank the
panelists and I want to thank all of you
and Yusuf I think this is going to be an
annual affair thank you
you